منطفا اب نار للتصعيد العسكري بين اسرائيل
والفلسطينيين الا واوقد رئيس الحكومه
الاسرائيليه بنيامين نتنياهو اخرى بنفس
الذريعه الا وهي القضاء على ما لا يقل عن
وصفه بالعنف والارهاب الفلسطيني كيف نفهم
رهان حكومه نتنياهو على التصعيد العسكري
ضد المقاومه ما هي خيارات الفلسطينيين
تجاه هذا التصعيد ما ملامح الوضع الذي
ستذهب نحوه الضفه الغربيه وعامه المنطقه
بعد انتهاء العمليه العسكريه الاسرائيليه
اسرائيل كانت
اولا
القضاء على الارهابيين داخل جنين وتوقيف
الارهابيين
وتدمير البنى التحتيه للارهاب في جنين
الانجاز الثاني والذي لا نعرفه اليوم بعد
سوف يتطلب الامر وقتا لكي نعرف ما اذا تم
تحقيقه هو منع من ان تكون جنين ملادا امنا
للارهابيين لا اعتقد ان الناس ترى ان هذه
العمليات لا جدوى منها يجب ان نتذكر السبب
وراء هذه العمليات في المقام الاول وفقا
لاتفاقيه اوسلو منذ 30 عام واكثر ان
المنظمه او المجموعه التي كان يفترض ان
تكافح هؤلاء الارهابيين ومنع الارهابيين
من التغلغل في المدن فهو السلطه
الفلسطينيه ولكن في السنوات الاخيره
السلطه الفلسطينيه لا تقوم باي شيء
لمواجهتها هؤلاء وبالتالي يتعين على جيش
الاسرائيلي ان يقوم بهذه العمليات في داخل
المدن في كل ليله
بعد ما يقوله جيش الاحتلال ان عمليه ولاده
في يوم واحد ليس الا اعترافا بالحقيقه
الجليه التي ترينها عندما تذهب الى جنين
وهو ان الاحتلال فشل فشلا ذريعا والعمليه
الاسرائيليه فشلت فشلا كاملا لان هدفها
المركزي والاساسي والاول كان ضرب
المقاومين ولم تستطع ان تصل لهؤلاء
المقاومين او معظمهم كان فشلهم سيجلل الان
بالعار بعد ان قاموا بارتكاب جرائم حرب
وحشيه هي في الواقع ما يسمى ارهابا الجانب
الاخر للفشل للفشل وانا رايت اليوم في
شوارع الضفه الغربيه
انتفاضه شامله في كل القرى لا يوجد قريه
لا يوجد على مدخلها حواجز واشعال اطارات
واستضامات مع الجيش نفس الشيء في رام الله
في احياء القدس
ذاك فعلا مشكله حقيقيه هنا بسبب ان
نتنياهو وحكومته
اقتحموا الضفه الغربيه هذا امر امر تاريخي
نتحدث عن هجمات حصلت في جنين
لم تحصل منذ عشرين سنه وهذا يعني تصعيد
الرئيس بايدن ووزير خارجيه
بلينكن سيكون عليهما ان يبنوا على ما حصل
ويحاسب منح قام بذلك
يريد ان يتقاتل الفلسطينيون مع بعضهم
البعض يريد ان تكون بيننا حرب اهليه مقابل
ماذا ولماذا ومن قال ان حركه حماس حركه
معاديه للشعب الفلسطيني كلنا اخوه وكلها
حركات فلسطينيه وطنيه تناضل معا وتعمل معا
من اجل فلسطين اسرائيل تريد ان تكون
السلطه الفلسطينيه وكيل امني لها وتريد ان
يشتبك الفلسطينيون مع بعضهم البعض وهذا ما
يقوله هو المتحدثون الامريكيون هذا لن
يحدث ابدا الصراع لا يدور داخل المخيم فقط
مدينه جنين باكملها جبهه حرب والشباب
يقاومون ويناضلون بكل ما يستطيعون هذا شعب
يناضل ضد الارهاب ضد الاحتلال ان رئيس
الوزراء نتنياهو لم يواجه ازمه ما كان الا
ان يصعدها ودائما بشكل دائم يدفع الحدود
الى الى اقصى الحدود
بحيث يمنع تاشيرات العمل ويحدد
الترخيصات لاجراء المنازل او بناء المنزل
وهو يفقم ذلك ويصعد الامور خلال اداراتهم
مختلفه واداره بايدن لا تؤيد ذلك ولا تدعم
هذا وبالتالي التصعيد حاليا لابد ان يواجه
تخفيف التصعيد الارهاب هو ما تقوم به
اسرائيل الفلسطينيون ليسوا ارهابيين وانا
اتساءل كيف تريد يعني الولايات المتحده ان
تصف خصائل الفلسطينيه بانها ارهابيه
ومنظمه التحرير التي تريد منها ان تحارب
الفصائل التي تسميها ارهابيه مصنفه في
الولايات المتحده ايضا كمنظمه ارهابيه في
الكونجرس الامريكي والولايات المتحده لو
ارادت ان تحترم القانون الدولي وتحترم نفس
المعايير التي تحاول ان تستعملها في
اوكرانيا وغيرها لفرضت عقوبات على اسرائيل
لفرضت عقوبات لردع اسرائيل عند استيطان
ولكن ما نراه نفاق دولي نحن كشعب فلسطيني
لم
نعد ولا نريد ان نتكل على اطراف خارجيه
الشعب الفلسطيني وهذا ما رايته في شباب
جنين اليوم قرر الاعتماد على النفس وتنظيم
النفس وتوحيد طاقاته وهذه الوحده الوطنيه
الرائعه هي التي ستصنع طريق نصر الشعب
الفلسطيني ان شاء الله
ان ارادوا وقت التصعيد عليهم اولا ان
يوقفوا هذه العمليات العسكريه الاجراميه
التي تجري ضد الشعب الفلسطيني وان يوقفوا
ارهاب المستوطنين الذي مس بالفلسطينيين
وبعضهم حتى يحملوا الجنسيه الامريكيه في
قرى عديده عليهم ان يوقفوا الاستعمار
الاستيطاني وارهاب المستوطنين اولا قبل ان
يتحدثوا عن تهدئه او عن تحسين الاوضاع حق
الفلسطينيين السلطه الفلسطينيه بالوجود
وللشعب الفلسطيني بالنجود هو حق عميق
واساسي كما هو حق اسرائيل ان تعيش كدوله
اذا عن ماذا يتحدثون نحن واعون بما يجري
والشعب الفلسطيني واعي وانا متاكد ان هذا
الشعب سيواصل نضال لانه يدرك انه محق جلدك
مثل ظفرك